this video is sponsored by blinkist get
a seven day free trial 25 off link is
premium and enjoy two memberships for
the price of one by using the link in
the description
[Music]
13.8 billion years ago there is as far
as we know nothing
13.6 billion years ago a space rapidly
expands a slew of particles scatters
across it a Skyline of stars begins to
form 12.9 billion years ago gravity
brings together matter from across the
open Cosmic sea to form the first
galaxies islands of vast localized gas
and dust and Stellar objects held
together across gravitational strings
4.5 billion years ago a cloud of gas and
dust orbits a young star in a quiet
region of an ordinary Galaxy it
coalesces Tighter and Tighter eventually
forming a planet a single planet in a
single Galaxy amongst incalculable
others Across the Universe 3.8 billion
years ago life on this planet begins 2.6
million years tools are made and used by
living things
150 000 years ago language abstract
thinking and the burgeoning of culture
begins
on the scale of one minute the entire
history of modern Humanity lasted
roughly the last eight ten thousands of
a second put differently if the entire
history of the universe were compressed
into one day modern Humanity wouldn't
appear until after the last single
second a blink and each of our
individual lives take place within the
second lasting around four ten thousands
of that fraction of a fraction of a
fraction and the universe has only just
begun
here we are within this tiny
infinitesimal moment of time so tied up
with it with everything we are and
everything we do we think this sliver of
something means everything because to us
it does but to everything we mean
nothing
when referring to the pale blue dot
photo taken by the Voyager 1 space probe
showing Earth from a record distance
away Carl Sagan said
on that everyone you love everyone you
know everyone you ever heard of every
human being whoever was lived out their
lives the aggregate of our joy and
suffering thousands of confident
religions ideologies and economic
doctrines every Hunter and forager every
hero and coward every Creator and
destroyer of civilization every King and
peasant every superstar every supreme
leader every saint and sinner in the
history of our species live there on a
mode of dust suspended in a Sunbeam
think of the rivers of blood spilled by
all those generals and Emperors so that
in glory and Triumph they could become
the momentary masters of a fraction of a
DOT our posturings our imagined
self-importance the delusion that we
have some privileged position in the
universe are challenged by this point of
pale light our planet is a lonely Speck
and a great enveloping Cosmic dark
one day you appear on this planet soon
the days turn into a flip book your life
becoming an animated film containing
everything you know and care about
everything you fear and dread but what
feels like a film to you will in fact be
more like a single frame in an infinite
film to everything else
you don't know how you got here you
don't know why you're here you don't
know how any of this really works or
where any of it is going no one does
and before you know it you won't be here
at all no one will
don't worry like the entire history of
the universe before you the entire
future of it will be over before you
know it as well
if you're lucky in let's say 80 years
you close your eyes for the last time
your children grandchildren friends and
family whatever amount you still have
left if any attend your funeral they cry
for a little while then they mostly move
on they have to in order to survive
themselves
in 200 years all direct traces of you
are lost memories of you how you looked
talked and acted what you did and didn't
do the distant blur of your story have
all dissolved away with the last person
who knew of you by now all perceptions
of you had become inaccurate distortions
and projections anyway void of any
authentic connection
if you did something especially
noteworthy during your lifetime direct
traces of you may continue for a little
while but not much longer
in 100 000 years the 21st century is but
a strange section in the record of
History occasionally reflected on by
individuals that no longer relate to it
in any meaningful way
5 million years most of the Earth's
pre-existing species are extinct due to
the background Extinction rate they've
all been replaced with new species
one billion years
there is no life left on Earth
5.5 billion years the sun cools and
expands consuming the Earth completely a
once Lively Planet billions of years old
wiped out without a trace a grand finale
of a light show with no Ovation the sun
is dead the Earth is gone the universe
doesn't notice
there is so much time left
100 trillion years the last remaining
stars begin to die fading out and
burning up the grave sites are marked by
the Tombstones of newly formed black
holes the universe becomes an expanding
graveyard of the bones of evaporating
stars
one Duo decillion black holes swallow
all the remaining stray matter of the
universe they will soon be All That
Remains we will be here a while most of
the universe's lifetime is spent in
these demented elderly years
between one Google and one Googleplex
the last massive black hole evaporates
one last explosion of light and energy
occurs closing the final eye of the
universe
time is no longer everything that has
ever happened has now insofar as
everything is concerned never happened
the universe returns to nothing and
nothing happens forever
of course this is all speculation the
universe could be infinite it could be
cyclical it could be something else
entirely the story of the universe may
have gone and may continue to go nearly
an infinite number of different ways
most of which we likely can't even begin
to imagine let alone estimate and
predict what we can know however is that
somehow we are here a part of that story
of all the things that could exist of
all the things that never will for some
reason we are each one of the things
that does
while we are here we will experience
things we will cry we will laugh we will
hopefully love we will know what it
means to have awoken as an embodied
collection of dead particles onto a
strange lushly coated wet rock floating
through a vast expanse of energy and
matter made from and destined for
apparent nothingness we will worry we
will dread we will try we will fail we
will move on we will die we will be
forgotten
but for now we are here
in truth even if we could to fully take
in the profundity of what is going on in
every moment would rupture our ability
to carry out the everyday
but likewise not considering the
absurdity and Insanity of what's taking
place around and through us at least on
occasion can cause us to easily become
submerged into falsity into mundanity
into misunderstanding into unnecessary
anxiety and stress
while we are here our lives naturally
consume us but in the end insignificance
consumes all life
and considering this at least on
occasion can perhaps help us better see
and decide what we truly want to be
consumed by while we are still here
because soon the rest of the universe
will continue on indifferently until it
all ends or continues on forever
regardless you almost certainly won't be
around for any of it and it will all be
over so so quickly
blink
that's how long the rest of the universe
will feel
[Music]
this video was sponsored by blankest
with the new year now unfolding in the
sands of time piling up more behind us
now is always the time to do and work
toward the things we want in life
regularly reading and learning is an
essential component of this of becoming
who you are and understanding more about
the world crucial to reading and
learning however is efficiently locating
the right books and sufficiently
understanding their ideas otherwise you
can easily spend unnecessary amounts of
time and struggle to retain important
information blinkist is an amazing app
that helps you avoid this problem by
allowing you to easily build supplement
and accelerate an extremely strong
reading practice all while saving time
blinkus works by condensing over 5500 of
the best non-fiction books and podcasts
across 27 different categories into
around 15-minute explainers which can be
both read or listened to even while
offline meaning you can easily discover
new books new Authors and accelerate
your understanding of complex ideas even
while exercising running errands
commuting or during any other moments
throughout the day and no matter who you
are and what you want to focus on this
new year blinkist's tailored content and
exclusive personality driven guides can
help provide you with the perfect
reading roadmap if you're interested in
further exploring the cosmos blinkus has
a great curated collection called
understanding our vast Universe where
you can learn from nearly a dozen titles
about nearly all aspects of this absurd
place we exist like how the moon
inspired ancient mythology and evolve
through science fiction how he came to
visit it and how important it is to us
and Earth and Ben Moore's work titled
moon or understand the universe from the
perspective of Carl Sagan and his
classic work Cosmos and so much more and
now through blinkus connect premium
users can also share their account with
another person at no additional cost
letting you share whatever insights and
books you find with someone close to you
use the link in the description or scan
the QR code on the screen and you'll
receive a seven day free trial 25 off
link is premium and can enjoy two
memberships for the price of one the
seven day day free trial can be canceled
at any time within the trial period
and of course as always thank you so
much for watching in general and see you
next video